okay it's on okay okay what the [ __ ] man
all right we're wrong
we're having problems with YouTube
people sorry about that I have no idea
what yeah happened we haven't had that
happen in a long time no yeah it's not
it's not our internet connection it was
YouTube
yeah it must be some kind of technical
glitch or something because there's no
problem anywhere else
I can go to any other platform and it's
fine but YouTube itself is
acting a fool
well hopefully now I'm like paranoid
that it's gonna like [ __ ] off again and
I don't have any idea like how long I
was talking before not long it turned
off about a minute or so so I'm gonna
have to back up a little bit I mean I'll
just back up later they're all coming in
everybody's all coming back in all right
we got just three just jumped in
okay so just maybe somebody can tell me
where it cut off at
um well if you want I can go back and
replay the end of uh
the last segment
I mean like I said
YouTube is um
actually very glitchy right now
Danny said it was Joseph's evil ghost
yeah
all right look
I guess it spells
get out
and then
um they kind of hear a bunch of creaking
and [ __ ] and they're just like what the
[ __ ] man like what is that and then like
the message continues
get out or all
that's about when we lost it
Okay so okay that's about
okay and then we like we lose it right
around noon okay so that's fine so
actually I wasn't
I lost about a paragraph yeah of of
notes
okay half the audience is bad okay
that's good that's good yeah sorry about
that like I said I just
I'm so used to that not happening
anymore that I don't look at my little
square so I was just over here reading
and then I looked over and the square
was red so I didn't know how long it had
been like that yeah it wasn't our
service it was YouTube
yeah well like I said no other platform
[ __ ] fell and I went and checked both
routers they were just running fine I
think after I after we do the show I
think I need to update uh OBS as well so
that might have also been a problem
so maybe that's what it is but yeah so
uh let's get back okay they're all back
into it okay
so uh as I mentioned at the end of The
Last Thing Before we got cut off uh yeah
go spells out get her get out or I'll
kill you which like I said very rude so
um so the glass then moves by itself
and after that the glass Bells out help
me or please help me
so after that they supposedly here and
this was just on the show now the real
woman the real Kamala she said that uh
she confirmed that the that it spelled
out uh help me or whatever like on the
Ouija board but I don't know if they
really like heard like a little girl or
whatever
supposedly on the show they hear this
little girl like sighing or something
so kamyla said she immediately not sure
how she knew this but she said she
immediately knows this has to be the
same girl that the customer had seen in
the bathroom upstairs
and also the girl who left the handprint
in the jello
and she said that out loud and then the
glass slid over to yes as they're
replying yeah that's who I am so there's
that whole thing
um okay yeah you were talking about the
message get out or I'll kill you yeah
that's what I figured so I didn't lose
that much I only lose like a [ __ ] uh
yeah Rebecca said YouTube has been
difficult for months when y'all upload a
show I can't view it until 24 hours
after the upload I wonder why yeah like
because like I said I explained
sometimes and I don't know if this
affects it or not but like sometimes
I'll go in the next morning and like cut
off the five minutes of you know coming
soon at the beginning and then it'll
process but I don't know if you can
still watch it like while it's
processing if you can do it I wouldn't
worry about it nobody else does that
they just fast forward it or the other
the other uh shows that I watch they
leave that there
because you just fast forward it you
just press with your finger on your
little tablet
to the places where the show starts
that's all you got to do I know but it
just seems like well if you have five
minutes of [ __ ]
but if it delays the show 24 hours it
isn't worth it but see I don't know if
it does I think what it said it did I
think but I don't know if that's what it
is is what is what I'm saying I'm saying
that what YouTube says is that if you go
in there and like trim some off the
beginning like it will process but while
it's processing in theory it's supposed
to be showing the old version of the
video Until the processing is done so
you should still be able to watch it but
it still has the stuff that you trimmed
according to other creators that are
much bigger than us you YouTube's
[ __ ] up they've they've really kind
of broken YouTube because they put so
many AI algorithms in it to serve this
[ __ ] censorship that nothing really
works very reliably anymore
and it's evidently YouTube is kind of
going the way of Facebook it's supposed
to be it's a big platform because Smart
TVs come with it all right um but it's a
it's a platform that won't be around
five years from now so we'll we'll be on
another platform by then
uh other platforms are doing real well
there's no
hassles and no worries about censorship
and they still have payment processors
uh there's a lot of them coming up now
so
there's programs where you can stream on
six of them [ __ ] simultaneously and
that's casting an awful wide net because
just you can just get super chats off
six damn platforms simultaneously
So eventually we're going to have to
upgrade to that kind of stuff we'll be
on YouTube but that'll just be one of
them
we need to be on other ones two
but you know Jenny doesn't really want
to deal with it yet
well you know it's it's a lot of work
and I haven't and I'll have to like
spend ages like figuring out they're
gonna do it because and that's just like
I don't have to do programs for it I'm
sure I know but I just don't have time
to like learn to do something else again
yeah we just have to plan for the future
well I know that I know I'm just saying
I don't have time to deal with that
right some of the shows are making a
[ __ ] ton of money off of things like off
of the one of them that's doing real
well is Rumble rumble's making a lot of
money
uh and and it's because they have
live chats and they have payment
processors on it so they can send you
super chats and everything you know just
and the algorithms are a lot easier to
get noticed because you're not they're
not doing suppression and they're not
favoring corporate channels so the
competition's easier you're not being
held back artificially Danny Rowling
said the girl ghost in this episode
looks a lot older than six just saying
yeah I mean I you know they just got the
actors that they and honestly
the only reason that we know supposedly
that the girl is six years old is
because that's what the psychic said so
I don't know if the girl was actually
six or not
you know what I'm saying
uh so yeah so a few days later this is
kind of where the the big ghost story
[ __ ] like starts
so a few days later David the owner he's
hosting a fundraiser at the pub and some
of the people said oh you should have in
like some psychics to do psychic
readings and like you can raise money
that way it's like five pounds to get
your fortune red or whatever and like
you can raise money for kids cancer or
whatever the hell the charity was
so they have a bunch of psychics in
there
uh so at this point they talked to Pub
regular Martin Brown uh who will become
significant later on and he's just kind
of like I couldn't believe how stupid
this [ __ ] was like I was there that
night but you know we were talking about
oh my God the uh psychic thing it's like
I can't believe people are so stupid
that they believe in that kind of stuff
and bloody blah
um so two of the psychics that show up
are a woman named Suzanne hadwin who you
know she's kind of all over this [ __ ] uh
and there's another one I'm not sure
what her name is they it sounded like
Lana and I have no idea like what her La
her last name was like gravincemus or
something like that I couldn't tell what
he was saying
so Suzanne comes in and she says she
immediately felt some super super
negative energy like inside this place
she said it's anger like I've never felt
before in my life that's what she said
uh so she gives readings to people like
she's supposed to be doing but she said
she kept feeling this like negative vibe
in the back of her mind the whole time
and she was kind of having a hard time
concentrating and yada yada and she's
like there was really like no reason
that
um that I should have been feeling like
that Danny Rowling said that guy Martin
looked like he had a second row of teeth
in his mouth he did kind of now that she
even now that you mention it I there was
like something like kind of weird
looking about him but I couldn't put my
finger on it but that's kind of like I
don't remember that guy yeah that's kind
of like he was they didn't show him much
he was the real guy of the guy that got
possessed okay you know what I mean all
right he did kind of I didn't notice
anything anything about his teeth yeah
well I didn't know it was his teeth I
just thought there was something like a
little he wasn't like funny looking or
anything there was just something a
little bit weird about his face I guess
and it's just kind of like and I was
like oh yeah it did kind of look like he
had two sets of teeth I got you that's
what that's pretty funny all right so
um at one point a few hours later she's
kind of like doing a reading and she's
like I couldn't really you know get it
out of my head this whole like negative
thing and I wanted to like check it out
so she goes upstairs like just kind of
sort out like why she feels the way she
feels now supposedly while she's up
there she sees the ghost of a little
girl uh and she said and I quote you
could see right through her now
allegedly
nobody had told her prior to this uh
that the uh that the staff of the pub
had seen a little girl or that customers
had seen a little girl
you know I'm just saying I don't know if
I believe that or not but I'm just
saying like she allegedly didn't know
anything about that like before she came
in but so she's like she goes upstairs
and she sees
the ghost of a little girl
um and on the show they showed the
little girl saying like freaking out and
like being scared and everything and
saying please he's coming or something
like that and Suzanne said yeah you
could see her face and she looked really
scared and [ __ ] so the little girl like
kind of runs off and like fades in the
direction of the bathroom or whatever
so um so Suzanne goes into the bathroom
she doesn't see the little girl but then
when she looks in the mirror she said
she had this vision of presumably the
way the room used to look like back in
the day she said it used to be a bedroom
and that the bedroom presumably belonged
to this little girl now on the show they
said it looked about a century old so
around the turn of the century because
the show like I said came out in 2004
and I think like later on they tried to
say that the little girl had been
murdered in 1908 so it was like right
around that time period
so she said at this point she sees the
little girl in like sitting on the floor
of the bedroom and said her face looked
all beat up and the ghosts like asked
her for help and then there's like
another noise like somebody coming and
then the ghost looks like really scared
and disappears so then like the vision
that Suzanne's presumably been seeing in
the mirror like disappears and Suzanne
is like back in the normal bathroom
again
so later that night like after the pub
closes Suzanne tells the staff about
this girl that she saw and the fact that
the bathroom used to be a bedroom now
David said he was really impressed
because like pretty sure none of the
staff told this psychic woman that other
people had seen a little girl
so Suzanne is like do you mind if I have
a look around now that like nobody's in
here and he's like yeah sure fine it
even gives her like the keys to the
kitchen and blah blah because it had
already been locked up
so she goes into
um the locked kitchen and kind of hear
some weird noises and then there's like
a ghost of a man which is Joseph appears
behind her now she didn't say she saw
that although she did say I knew him so
I don't know if that means she sensed
him and she like knew who he was that
way like she knew because she's like she
said she instinctively knew that his
name was Joseph so I don't know if she
actually like saw him with her eyeballs
or not I don't know
um because at this point like the
narrator says that she was bombarded
with images from another time so I'm
guessing this was all like a vision that
she had not necessarily something that
she saw like I said with her eyes but
something she saw like in her mind or
whatever so the vision that she sees is
she sees Joseph and this other dude
carrying uh the screaming girl down into
the cellar like all wrapped in like a
big piece of material or something like
that
so at this point like the staff tell her
oh yeah like we talked to this little
girl through the Ouija board and Suzanne
like most psychics worth their salt will
do what the [ __ ] were you doing playing
with a Ouija board don't you know that
those things are like super dangerous
don't mess around with those it opens a
portal and then all kind of evil is
gonna you're letting evil into the world
she tells them that's the stock response
what it is every one of these in every
one of these shows when uh the the
psychic shows up and they found out you
this did that Ouija board well there it
is
the Ouija board what were you
[ __ ] what were you thinking
Parker Brothers God damn it
all right this one wasn't even Parker
Brothers it was just like a homemade one
it was just a homemade one yeah so it's
like I don't really see how
I don't know man
um any kind of spiritual activity by you
novices you know if you want if you want
to do spiritual activity you better hire
me I'll come down here and do it that's
what they're that's that that's that's
that's what they're trying to say
but you know that's what they believe
though yeah that's true okay I don't
think they're making it up that response
but they believe that
um
I don't think that Ouija board makes any
difference yes no I don't think that we
no I've seen paranormal [ __ ] and had
nothing to do with Ouija boards
could a Ouija board evoke some
paranormal stuff
I would take the right kind of people it
would take the kind of people would take
a poltergeist Focus somebody who would
do who could do it even without the damn
Ouija board
Ouija board would just be a crutch
so I don't know Murder Hornet said
Fisher Price yeah Fisher prices my first
week
it's made of plastic and it squeaks like
for babies yeah so you can contact
spirits you're a toddler that'd be kind
of cool
[Laughter]
what they're thinking though they're
thinking that if you're messing around
with
paranormal forces you can just unlock
something you're not ready to deal with
so maybe it's good advice maybe it's
good I mean even in The Exorcist she was
playing with a Ouija board yeah I think
so I think a lot of it comes from the I
think it does too that's the thing I
kind of feel like people forget how much
yeah
um stuff that is sort of taken for
granted in the Paranormal world like
came from a movie originally yeah
sometimes
or probably a lot of times
when they're writing the scripts to
those movies
they usually like went to some
parapsychology department for ideas so
it could be that whoever wrote the
script to The Exorcist
actually did that wasn't their idea for
the Ouija board it might have been a
parapsychologist that [ __ ] said oh
yeah if you mess around that Ouija board
you're unlocking psychic abilities that
you can't control you know and ghosts
and demons might an outside forces might
come through
but my mouse pad right that's right here
is a Ouija board so you'd think if any
place was like be infested with demons
it would be this office because I use
that all the time it's like it's on the
side because it's like it doesn't fit
but yeah the I have my I have a Ouija
board I don't think it's these little
trinkets that are the problem yeah the
problem is always Faith your belief
faith is the most powerful one
uh especially if you if you have uh what
Stephen King called the shine to you and
most people do shine at least a little
yeah so
matter of fact living creatures tend to
shine
yeah even even cats and [ __ ]
just not in the same way that human does
Pookie does for real it's life force I
know you guys will think I'm crazy but
I'm pretty sure Pookie can read my mind
yeah can read my thoughts
because sometimes I can call her with my
mind like I'm laying in bed it's the
middle of the night and I just go and I
think about Pookie and she'll come in
and be like what
why are you calling me Danny Rowling
said I'm surprised the dead prostitutes
that Joseph killed didn't haunt the
place as well we'll see now that's
something I want to get into because
they implied on the show they did
actually kind of imply this where they
were I think there was one point where
the psychic said oh you know we need to
get rid of Joseph and then we can deal
with all the other spirits and then
somebody said well how many more are
they and she said I don't know but in
some of the articles about this that I
read
um apparently she did know because she
said that there were 37 of them
she said there were 37 Spirits in there
uh several of which were murder victims
and actually I think she said eight of
them were murdered children I don't know
but you know and one of them was Joseph
obviously but I'm assuming like the
other ones were maybe other murder
victims as well
uh Rebecca says only need to be eight
years old to be able to use a Ouija
board but 21 to drink alcohol in the U.S
right
man the lady let anybody use that Ouija
board summoned demons and whatnot That's
like [ __ ] hilarious yeah okay
um Danny rolling said but even when the
Ouija board first came out there was
still Eerie [ __ ] that went on with it
and the user supposedly like you said in
the Ouija board uh show you did yeah I
mean I don't know I just to me it just I
don't I don't really believe in it but
you know that's what are you gonna do
Rebecca said I was going to start making
designer Ouija board Ouija blood boards
but holy [ __ ] at the church folk up in
my face telling me I'm being lured by
demons
yeah I don't I don't get it either I
mean I would have thought that after the
whole satanic Panic thing had gone away
like that people but honestly like even
nowadays in 2022 I heard some people
were freaking out about Hocus Pocus 2
like that was gonna like lure children
into demonology and stuff like that and
I'm like seriously
that's what I mean I was like have we
learned nothing
people are just as stupid as they were
back then
you know what I mean yeah we people
aren't getting any smarter it's really
disappointing but yeah um
Rebecca said no brains no headache sure
I mean you know
so uh so yeah so obviously so yeah
you're not allowed to play with a Ouija
board she's like what the [ __ ] are you
even doing
um you're letting evil into the world
she tells them so as I said she tells
them well you have to get rid of Joseph
before you can help the little girl
because they all want to help this
little girl like get free or whatever
and deal with the other spirits that are
there like I said that's all she said in
this episode but in the uh in an article
that I read about this she said that
there were she specified that there were
37 which that sounds like some that
sounds like some uh Warren's [ __ ] right
there where they walk in and I was like
oh man you got like dozens of demons in
here like we're gonna have to be here
for a really long time uh but yeah
so a few nights later after closing they
do this sort of like ritual I guess
they're trying to like rescue the little
kids Soul or whatever so they do a
cleansing first to protect everybody so
Suzanne apparently believes that
Joseph's spirit is concentrated in the
basement concentrated ghost uh so she
sends them I don't know why this made me
laugh so hard but she sends the staff
down there and makes them stand like she
makes a salt Circle and she makes them
all stand in it and she's basically like
well I'm gonna go upstairs and see if I
can like help this little girl you guys
stay down here and hoping that they can
detain Joseph in the basement like in
the salt Circle or I'm not really sure
it wasn't clear
um so yeah so she's gonna make them stay
down there in the salt circle like
praying and stuff like that to keep
Joseph down there so she can like deal
with the the little girl upstairs
so Suzanne goes into the bathroom first
and then turns on she has like a little
tape recorder like for EVPs or whatever
and then they go into this it looked
like a storage room I'm assuming that's
what it was and Suzanne like I guess she
sensed that the kid was in there so they
do another salt Circle it was actually
more of like a salt oval really
um not really all that circular what are
you doing damn Pokey
she's like no it's nothing I do what I
want she's like tearing the couch
um yeah so
so she does another salt Circle and then
puts a little doll in the middle of it
as though it's bait like ghost bait
which I was again I thought was very
funny
so Lana the other psychic she's what
they call a psychic artist uh which
basically means she just like senses
spirits and she like draws what they
look like you know what I mean so
there's that
so Suzanne somehow gets the name Jessica
and she assumes that that's what the
little girl's name is so she asks
Jessica what she's afraid of and then
they hear like something creaking around
like out in the hall
um the real Suzanne then says you know
you didn't have to ask if Joseph was
around you just knew because you could
feel it like apparently it was like this
really really bad like negative energy
so then she says that she had a vision
of Joseph and the other guy like
throwing the kid on the floor and it
looked like beating her to death now in
the article that I read
she actually said that the vision that
she had was that the guy and the other
guy like Joseph and the other guy had
actually raped the little girl and then
cut her up
and then like put her in a bag or
something like that and put her in the
floor so they didn't share that on the
show they basically just showed him like
beating her to death with like an ax
handle which is bad enough for crazy but
yeah she it was a lot worse like in what
she said in the article
so she asks Jessica where her body is
and apparently the Ghost says I'm still
here and then appears like with her hand
like on the wall like in the storage
room so Suzanne is like she's in the
wall like they must have walled her up
behind there so we need to get her out
so meanwhile downstairs uh kamyla
accidentally steps out of the salt
circle and has some kind of like episode
uh she said she could she basically like
falls to the ground and starts like
wigging out or whatever and see she said
that she couldn't control her legs and
she had like this really horrible pain
in her head she said when she stepped
out of the circle like something touched
her face like something that felt evil
and it was like suffocating her like she
couldn't breathe so that she had like a
really bad episode she recovered it was
okay though
so then uh the other the psychics come
back down
and they listen to the audio recorder
that they had had going in the bathroom
while all of these Shenanigans were
going on now on this EVP uh there's a
man's voice on there basically telling
Suzanne Suzanne that he's gonna kill her
so this is essentially that means the
ghost is like operating in real time
this isn't one of those kind of like
reliving the past or anything like that
because he's talking to Suzanne who's
there right now uh and he's like yeah
I'm gonna kill you so Suzanne is like
well that's a little uh alarming but
they all decide that um they're just
gonna go ahead and help Jessica because
they want her to go to heaven or
whatever
so that night because the psychic is so
convinced that Jessica's body is behind
this wall
David the guy that owns places are like
okay fine you can kind of tear the wall
down and see if you find anything don't
make too much of a mess he says and then
he goes home presumably to sleep for a
couple of hours
so they kind of tear out it looks like
there was like drywall like put over it
I don't know what it was like in real
life so they tear like all of that off
and they find like this brick fireplace
behind the wall
now apparently all they said on the show
was that they found like a bit of
concrete that had some hair on it like
that looked like that's I don't know it
just looked like human hair and a small
piece of what might may or may not have
been bone although I don't know if it
was human bone I mean what they showed
on the show was like a little bitty
piece now in the articles that I read
they said they found a lock of hair
um Rags that look like from a girl's
dress and like the heel of a child's
shoe they didn't say anything about
bones okay so I'm just saying but to say
they showed on the show a little bitty
piece of bone or whatever but the way
that the real Suzanne talked about it
she was saying like I was holding the
girl's remains in my hand so maybe a
little bit of exaggeration not entirely
misleading it's a little misleading yeah
and the thing is it's like even if you
found like a little piece of bone in
there that could be I mean it could be
lots of things it could be an animal
you know yeah so it wouldn't necessarily
even be human it just it would have to
be verified yeah that's what I mean
you'd have to find like a skull or
something and maybe from a case that's
totally unrelated to the story that
you're that too that too
Charlie Huck says hi from Argentina love
you guys we love you too yep
Argentina
went there a long time ago
yeah that's right for a couple days yeah
um yeah so it's funny because they
pulled they pull all the drywall out
like it's such a one rim and like I said
it looked like a storage room or
whatever like I said I don't know what
it was in my life but David comes back a
few hours later and was like what the
[ __ ] I thought I just like that I
thought I told you not to make a mess
because they did kind of make a mess in
the place like tearing out this big
thing
um so after that like they all
apparently hear a girl's voice saying
help me it's like coming from downstairs
so they all run down there but there's
nobody there and at that point like
kamyla said she saw like a weird shadow
that wasn't quite a shadow like almost
like a shadow like going up the stairs
or whatever like nosferati or whatever
but it's like um what
I've seen what she was doing oh
usually you said something no she was
pulling on you didn't you didn't see
what she was doing no I didn't see it
she grabbed the corner of that damn
little ottoman was trying to pull on it
was like she was hung up I think she got
[ __ ] yeah her claws get stuck yeah
because then she's just like yeah she
couldn't she couldn't detach
Willow says hello Jenny Tom Pookie
yeah I think Pookie just walked out
but yeah so then Suzanne apparently
starts having a vision of Joseph sitting
at a table like in the corner of the pub
and she starts like talking to him
um obviously nobody else could see him
but she's like over there like talking
to him so she's able to determine from
this Vision that Joseph was running a
brothel and that he really really hated
women now she keeps asking him like why
he killed Jessica and finally he says at
least on the show he says she got in my
way and if you get in my way you'll die
too that's what he says
so Suzanne says well I couldn't like I
was scared but I couldn't like back down
from him because you know he'd be able
to like get in or whatever
so
um she tells the staff well he's getting
stronger we don't have much time we need
to get rid of this [ __ ]
so they go to the library and Suzanne
and I think it was Tim like one of the
bartenders they go and they do some
research now apparently I don't know if
this is true or not again uh they find a
picture in a book they find a book like
that's the history of the town or
whatever and they find a picture in
there that shows a man that apparently
looks like the man she saw in her vision
sitting at a corner table at the wheat
Chief and she said oh that's him that's
Joseph she also finds a picture of like
a Sunday school class that has a little
girl in it that she thinks looks like
Jessica the little girl that she saw in
the pub
I don't know if this has been verified
or not so nothing happens at the pub for
several days they said Martin uh Martin
who's the guy that comes there all the
time he's like the pub regular he
claimed that prior to all of this all of
this stuff happening that he had never
heard anything about the pub being
haunted even though he was there a lot
um but he's about to find out some [ __ ]
as we'll get into now there's also a
little incident too where Camilla is
like really really nervous because she
said the [ __ ] was getting worse and she
drops a tray with a bunch of glasses on
it and then like she looks up at the bar
and there's like a little it's like a
little cement like a kind of like a wall
sconce or like something that you'd
mount on the wall like to put a candle
or some [ __ ] on and it looked like it
was made of cement or whatever
and she looked at it and she said it saw
it was like wiggling like like on the
wall and she's like hey look that's
moving and then like it flew off and she
ducked real quick they said she hadn't
ducked at least that's what they said
that it probably would have like smashed
her skull because it was like super
heavy but yeah but she got out of the
way like uh quick enough but it Miss so
it missed her head so she said at that
point
um she knew because it was getting like
super violent that there was gonna be
some kind of like big uh Showdown
so a few hours after that it's like the
middle of the night now Lana the other
psychic the one that that draws that
draws [ __ ] she apparently gets a
premonition that David the owner was
going to be pushed down the stairs not
at the pub at his house by Joseph like
Joseph is going to come down here I
don't know how close this house was to
the pub but he's gonna come down the
street to your house and push you down
the stairs
so he's like um I thought it was funny
like the actor was like in a little late
late at night for premonitions why are
you calling me in the middle of the
night she's like well excuse me I
thought you were gonna fall down the
stairs and die because like a ghost was
gonna push you so she does like actually
warn him now apparently they didn't
really say this outright but I got the
implication because he seemed kind of
impressed that she knew some [ __ ] so I'm
assuming that maybe she knew like the
layout of his house even though she'd
never been there or something like that
because he seemed to like take it pretty
seriously so he's like okay I'll be
careful and he turned out okay like
nothing bad happened but they just like
added that little thing in there so uh
what are you gonna say something yeah I
was gonna say yeah Charlie Huck from
Argentina that's a trip that we got
people all the way in Argentina
listening to how the hell did you find
this show that's [ __ ] funny
it's just as easy to find it anywhere in
the world
yeah
I don't know maybe I didn't go to
Argentina I went to uh Montevideo at
maybe I think that might have been
Uruguay
oh a Paraguay
I'm not sure I went to Argentina
I went to the place of three Frontiers I
don't think [ __ ]
Trace frontieres but I don't think
that's I don't think Argentina is there
this place where Brazil and [ __ ]
couple other down
countries meet
I don't think I went there but I had
when I lived in Brazil I had I had
friends from Argentina went to school
with them
it's funny how similar our cultures are
as far as far away as that is
Argentina's just [ __ ] far from the
rest of the world if you look at the
globe upside down it's Argentina by
itself and [ __ ] Antarctica that's
what that's what the world looks like
from their point of view
I guess from a technical standpoint
um the globe can't really even be upside
down because no if you looked at it
upside down well yeah I know from there
I'm being a well actually one yeah
you're being well
yeah I was like technically yeah
technically yeah yeah
well no that's what I'm saying there's
no such thing as like a top or bottom
like we're just used to seeing it that
way because that's how we see the globe
yeah well if you turn it upside down and
look at Argentina it's by itself
it's up it's just there with the with
Antarctica
it's uh they're so lonely lonely out of
the middle of [ __ ] nowhere and then
Australia on the other side of it that's
kind of that's pretty weird yeah
all right so uh so Lana at this point
um she says yeah she felt like because
she got this premonition about Joseph
like expanding his reach apparently and
like pushing people down the stairs like
a few buildings over she's like okay
well the energies are building up uh
shit's getting worse so we really have
to like you know
you know bring this uh bring this all to
to a close
so one night so the staff are up kind of
sorting through the bricks where the
body supposedly was I guess they were
looking for more clues or bones or
something like that so Martin the guy
this was the best part I thought
he wanders upstairs and he comes into
the room where they're working and he
sees them and he starts kind of like
poking around in the bricks and they're
like Martin what the [ __ ] are you doing
like why are you even up here because he
doesn't work there
and he apparently gets possessed and he
starts acting like really really weird
so he's like picking he picks up one of
the bricks that has like green on it and
he looks at them like really creepily
and he says creepily he's like if you
want to find her look for the green
paint like the way he says it is like so
so creepy and I was like I was we were
watching it last night I'm like oh that
was so good I love the way he said that
that was like awesome so Props to that
actor because he did a good job
um so they're like well wait a minute
how do you know that like if you find
her like we didn't tell you that we were
looking for a little girl's body up here
so how do you know that
um you know and he says the little
girl's buried he says she's buried
behind the green bricks
and then they're like what the [ __ ] are
you talking about and he says oh she's
here and so is he that's what he said
it's like he was just so good at this
part it was so good so so creepy and
then he just like gets up and like walks
out the room and like drops the brick
but then he turns around and he like
yells at them and he says the girl is
mine he says so he's yeah he's possessed
so they start chasing after him because
the psychic is like we can't let him
leave the pub with the ghost I guess you
know what I mean you can't let him like
his possessed ass like running around in
the [ __ ] streets or whatever with a
lead from Korea Ms Lee's in there saying
don't play with the Ouija board she used
to do with the high school with her
friends it was creepy
I don't remember anything all that
exciting happening
I don't even remember messing with
anything like that yeah we I mean we had
one and like we played with it a few
times but I don't remember anything like
I said I don't remember anything all
that mostly a feature at girls slumber
parties
back in the 70s I remember yeah yeah
well I think me I had one and um I think
me and my brother and my sister maybe
did it a couple times but it's like it
nothing ever exciting happened
you know yeah that was like some [ __ ] my
babysitter Kimmy would bust out yeah
yeah I mean I could see why it'd be kind
of fun and everything when I was a
little kid her and all her little
[ __ ] hit I was like [ __ ] man that's
what we should maybe we should maybe we
should do that on uh the Halloween show
because I have a Ouija board right here
yeah no
oh my God I'm not pushing it you guys
that's what I would do but um yeah well
I can't do it now because I just said it
out loud but uh but yeah
so they chase after Martin because they
don't want to leave the pub so this is
great I'm not really sure like how they
got him to do this
but the next scene they show they make
Martin like sit in a chair and he's
apparently like still Martin sometimes
he's like what the [ __ ] are you guys
doing he's like can you just like sit in
this chair like for a second and then
like they make like a salt ring around
him and he's like what the [ __ ] are you
guys doing and he's like just trust us
it's fine
um so and then they start like
addressing him as Joseph and he's like
what the [ __ ] are you guys talking about
like what is going on so but then like
Suzanne said that she started talking to
Martin and calling him Joseph and then
Martin started looking like super Super
Evil and then he starts like talking in
like a different voice and he's like you
guys rituals or whatever like a really
pathetic you'll live to regret this yada
yada so they start like praying over him
and like telling Joseph to leave and at
this point Suzanne said she had another
Vision this time of Joseph murdering
another woman and Jessica the little
girl seeing it and that hence why
um you know Joseph ended up killing her
because she apparently likes awesome she
wasn't supposed to say
so Suzanne apparently draws Joseph out
of Martin's body and into a pendulum
dowser thingy she's got like that you
know the pendulum thing and she's kind
of like doing this she's like bringing
drawing the spirit into the thing like
using her Spirit guides to draw the evil
spirit into the little pendulum and he's
like no I won't go no no
he's like freaking out if he won't go
but he does uh in the end because you
know because the power of the Spirit
guides and Jesus and all that so the
pendulum they said was like going all
crazy Spirit gets sucked into the
crystal thingy so then Martin wakes up
and the real Martin said I didn't
remember anything that happened he's
like last thing I remember I was walking
upstairs like before he even went to the
room and said the creepy [ __ ] about the
green paint and all that kind of stuff
he did he says that he doesn't remember
any of that happening so he just he said
one minute I was walking up the stairs
and then next minute I was like waking
up in a chair be like and everybody was
like did it work did it work like and
he's just like what the [ __ ] is going on
like he didn't really know but the weird
thing though he said was that even
though he didn't really remember what
had happened
he actually somehow knew that uh it's
it's like the the ghost that had been in
there had like left residue that's gross
I had left like spiritual residue like
burnt toast I had left some bird toast
in there had left some [ __ ] like lying
around like inside his psyche or
whatever so um so he's like so he just
knew that oh the guy's name was Joseph
he was a bar man he ran the brothel in
here and he was like a real [ __ ] um
you know exploiting young girls killed a
bunch of people blah blah and apparently
they hadn't told him any of this ahead
of time so they were like weirded out
that he knew this
so at this point like Suzanne believes
that now Joseph is [ __ ] off I was kind
of like how did they kind of left me
hanging because she supposedly draws I
think about this kind of stuff this the
Practical concerns she supposedly draws
Joseph an evil spirit a powerful evil
spirit into a crystal on the end of a
pendulum it's like what does she do with
it now does she still have it someplace
is he still in there did she smoosh it
did she flush it down the toilet like
what what do you do with it now
um
like is it like the ghost containment
thing like in Ghostbusters you have to
put it like you have to transfer it to
like a facility that kind of is
protected against that kind of stuff or
what I'm curious you know they always
they never they never like they never
follow up on it make sure you guys like
Friend And subscribe and share the
channel for us and Jenny and I have
um Instagrams we've got 13 o'clock Park
13 o'clock podcast Instagrams we have
our own private Instagram got Jenny
Ashford Instagram no I just I
transferred mine to 13 o'clock okay I
got time I do have a scare Salon one
though too I got Thomas Ross Instagram I
got Thomas Ross Facebook
Jenny's got Facebook you can uh friend
us there if you're on the show I got 40
million Facebook things make sure to
make sure to friend
and um
we'll uh we'll have fun
Rebecca said put it in the house like
the Warrens that's what I'm thinking
it's like does she have like a bunch of
different because I'm you know you can't
put like more than one spirit and one
Crystal or can you
can you just like stuff a whole bunch of
them in there
do you have to do you have to write on
there like which ones are in there so
you don't forget like what kind of
person that does what if they escape
well asking a person that doesn't have
any creativity I'm not asking you
necessarily I'm just like it's a
rhetorical question yeah I'm just saying
if anybody knows please tell me because
they never tell me where you capture
spirit and what happens to it yeah put
it in a bottle like a gene like a gin
maybe that's what they do yeah you can
sell it on eBay it says Mark maybe they
do yeah
out of body experiences all right
there's not gonna be no way to trap any
kind of Soul it just [ __ ] go through
any material it can [ __ ] jump around
through space-time they can't be
captured
so that's in your [ __ ] mind
we'll see that's kind of what you might
be able to get rid of one just by
actually one of the most credible uh
stories about a guy getting rid of the
demon is he counseled it
and made friends with it it solved its
problems it's like something a Taoist
monk would do or a Buddhist monk might
do that
which would be kind of a more subtle wet
form of exorcism
Christians and Muslims would drive it
out with Force
which might strengthen it and make it
more negative I don't think that'd be
that wise
but that one Christian guy [ __ ] made
friends with that remember the guy in
the damn house that's more like
something a Buddhist would do or a
Taoist priest might do that which is to
solve the ghost's problems
yeah now
it's kind of like the the Judo away
don't [ __ ] knock it out just roll
with it you know
that seems like it would make more sense
I mean yeah but wait wasn't that the
same episode though where he was jogging
a couple months later and saw the ghost
like down the street yeah but he got rid
of it later on by by uh remember he he
loved it oh that's right yeah he healed
it that's right which is like more like
something my Buddhist would do
would try to heal the [ __ ] the heal
the pain and suffering of the spirit so
it can move on they don't do a lot of
that on that well I could they do that
on a Christian mindset well they do that
on a haunting but they usually only do
that on a haunting if it's a nice ghost
like if it's a little kid or something
it's like well you need to go to heaven
well that's what they did on this
prejudiced yeah well it's like an evil
ghost you'd think that they would need
it even more yeah right because they're
clearly very angry and have some issues
the the Christian
Christianity in Islam is very very
similar if you come across something
that's evil you don't negotiate whether
you try to destroy it
well you're meeting force with Force so
it's going to man up and get even
stronger all right you might be able to
win in a battle of wills eventually but
that's dangerous it might be better to
just counsel it and try to heal it so it
can move on that's a lot
more Shinto you know what I'm talking
about more or not what no no what's the
name of the [ __ ] that [ __ ] uh Steven
Seagal used what's that [ __ ] [ __ ]
that you used uh
uh Aikido more Aikido you know throw it
and [ __ ] move it on type of Deal or
just bring in Steven Seagal and The
Ghostly in Terror
Steve is the God shows up and goes I
heard your I heard you're haunting this
place
Steven Seagal Exorcist yeah yeah
I suspect you're here for an Asian
experience
but I don't share my women
so you're gonna have to go
when he finds out the ghost is black so
he adopts the black accent because
Steven Seagal's whatever ethnic group
he's talking about yeah if he's talking
to a black guy he becomes black
[ __ ] that's just [ __ ] funny
I mean if he's talking to Italian Guys
he becomes Italian
foreign
and he's Jewish now yeah it's funny I
mean
actually please somebody write a
screenplay called Steven Seagal Exorcist
I would watch that with it and it has to
have all of that stuff in it too like
he's just kind of like relating to every
ghost on their level and in their
ethnicity I saw I saw some recent would
be super fun I saw some recent video of
[ __ ] Seagal on on YouTube and he was
kind of making fun of himself so I think
he's realized that he's a meme
because he he can't fight it now oh well
that's what I mean I'm glad because it's
like some people like that this yeah
some people like that they don't have
any self-awareness they don't have any
self-sensitive humor about themselves
okay he had humor about it and it's hard
to get that later on in your life if you
don't have it you know what I mean so it
is nice to see I think he's changed a
little bit
I kind of wish Chuck Norris would
[ __ ] lighten up now Chuck Norris will
never change that's what I'm saying but
at least see if Steven Seagal can
lighten up then there's hope for
everyone maybe Chuck Norris is [ __ ]
bolstering himself to the transition
into the Afterlife is what he's doing
he's gonna go to God but behind the
Pearly Gates and all that that's what
he's doing yeah okay yeah he's gonna go
out [ __ ] kicking his way to heaven
Saint Michael
[Laughter]
yeah they're gonna send him back as an
angel yeah
Chuck Norris afterlife is amazing yeah
you made that up yeah that's a good one
yeah
yeah Chuck Norris didn't like to be a
meme that's what I'm saying I'm like the
thing about it is that that generation
did not understand if it happened if it
happens you might as well just roll with
it because you can't fight it you can't
yeah um and people are gonna be a lot
more charitable toward you if you just
like you know if you have a sense of
humor about it if you take yourself way
too seriously and get all butt hurt then
that's gonna make people like pick on
you even more you know what I mean
because that's just how it goes that
generation did not [ __ ] get into this
uh choking around the the joking around
[ __ ] uh uh dang they didn't they
didn't like that they wanted to be taken
seriously they were credibility
[ __ ]
that you know if you weren't taking them
seriously then you were disrespecting
them
see I don't get that yeah but yeah that
is a very that's a big thing like from
that generation yeah that generation
yeah I don't give a [ __ ] if anybody
takes me seriously or not it's not
important
[Laughter]
I don't give it I don't really know it
doesn't matter Isabella said I'd store
them old food jars because they're free
and you can mark their names on the list
with a sharpie yeah I'd even wash them
out first
yeah here you go ghosting you could put
the date on it and like what the what
the ghost did and like where you got
them from and you could like keep them
in your pantry or whatever see that'd be
neat man for some reason it just
cross my mind I got to go down there and
make maybe do something like make
refried beans out of the damn instapot
instant pot
is that what you just thought yeah I got
attacked by the idea of refried beans
that's how it is people attacked by the
idea of refried that almost sounded like
a Chuck tingle book yeah
taking a picture of me pound it in the
butt
by the refried beads
that pounded me in the butt
and it wasn't gay
also there was a unicorn and a unicorn
and Bigfoot and a dinosaur probably
dinosaur unicorn dinosaurs
and a billionaire in there with a
billionaire yeah and refried I need to
check back up on Chuck tingle because
like I said the [ __ ] writes a
new thing like every day it seems like
yeah and if seriously if you're having a
bad day and you need like just a good
laugh go to Chuck tingles Wikipedia page
and just read the titles just the titles
of all of his and you'll you will just
have a delightful day because they are
just I can't even get to the bottom of
the list and I'm just like crying from
laughter I recommend
Chuck tangle erotic novels to Miss Lee
Miss Willow Lee up in Korea read that
[ __ ]
you will be [ __ ] laughing all right
just read the titles
yeah you didn't hear me I mean you could
read the whole thing too they're still
they're fun but just the titles Chuck
tangle are funny enough just look up
Chuck tingle I mean that dude is like
some kind of marketing genius yeah he's
a genius yeah and I like that he's like
keeps he doesn't really do like
interviews he won't really say much
about like his history or his real name
like he makes some stuff up but he's
like real sketchy he is also a martial
artist that's right according to the
photograph that yeah yeah I kind of like
too that his uh that his author photo
was just like a stick figure that he
drew no well for a long time it was it
was that dude in that in that [ __ ] uh
in that uh karate
in that karate outfit when I saw it I
don't think that was actually even him
no of course that was a stock photo yeah
it was a stock photo a stock photo but
for a long time he had like a he had a
stick figure in a red karate outfit
[Laughter]
dating Rowling said add some tomatoes in
the refried beans Tom like the strippers
added to the biscuits and gravy yeah I
didn't understand it you guys saw that I
have never heard of that ever who the
hell puts tomatoes and biscuits of gravy
like I said what [ __ ] planet are you
from I don't know it's just you know
that I never heard of that it was
the strippers are three generations of
strippers and some of them were not as
young as I thought they were the one
that I thought was like a teenager she
was actually turning 29 but she looked
real young
so the ones that looked like they were
15 or 16 were probably more like 19 or
20. well I hope they were everything you
don't want a 15 year old strippers I
thought well I thought they were like
daughters yeah they weren't daughters to
the other ones they were just uh
co-workers
and uh
yeah they had it in a dam
crock pot keep on warm just one of the
things it was right next to me and it
didn't have any smell
and I didn't know them girls I don't
know if I want to eat out of their house
you know
but dude was he like they didn't have
any biscuits but they had
uh what was it had some french bread so
I'm just going to use that I was like
they must not be biscuits and gravy
[ __ ] it looks like but he was eating
it it had tomatoes in it he goes yeah
it's like
because it's hamburger it's not sausage
oh okay so maybe it wasn't even supposed
to be biscuits and gravy no
but it didn't make any sense it was
something somebody made up that's not a
traditional thing that's not a
traditional southern thing
it was based on biscuits and you know of
countries whatever they had in their
house they were like yeah whatever yeah
it was like country gravy but not really
yeah now they probably threw Rotel in it
well you know we always throw a hotel in
there yeah and Roti just drained a Rotel
put it in there with it yeah Rotel is
good it is yeah very good it's actually
a Rotel and Velveeta make like the
quintessential dip party dip
in the South actually in the midwest too
it's a big thing in the midwest rotel's
great in any kind of Indian recipe
because it has it had diced tomatoes and
green chilies in it already it's already
got the spices so you can put that in
there put that in the early parts of
making a curry
you know it works good we'll see now a
lot of the uh some of the channels that
I watched that are trying to do like you
know good food like on a budget like
from the Dollar Tree or whatever they
said well it's always good like
especially if you live somewhere or you
don't have like a lot of spices in your
house it's always good to like buy cans
of Rotel that already have like spices
in them so then like you don't have to
add [ __ ] because it's already in there
so you know what I mean and Roads cans
of Rotel and [ __ ] are like really cheap
so uh
uh
um
you know sucked Joseph out of the sucked
Joseph out of the out of Martin's body
and put him in the Crystal and then did
whatever with the crystal I'm not
entirely sure um but maybe I should call
her and ask him guy we got we got
[ __ ] Gourmet Rotel we must have nine
different flavors of it here
all right some of it's a roasted some of
it's mild hot some of it's got damn uh
they got chipotle they got all different
kinds of flavors now okay that's all I
just don't
I was just uh answering what he said
about he said some of it's pretty hot
they got all kinds of flavors now same
with Spam they got 20 different flavors
of spam
well that's kind of the thing like every
every food brand nowadays man you gotta
have like 50 bajillion flavors you got
to have like yeah tons of flavors of
everything yeah the bacon flavor is good
slice it thin and use it as a just
breakfast sandwich you know
good egg and cheese
and breakfast sandwich yeah he made a
breakfast sandwich last night after the
show was really really good yeah sausage
and
yeah it was good actually yeah it was
really good
uh but yeah so now that Joseph is [ __ ]
off and is still living in the crystal
just like uh just like the villains in
Superman like inside the thing I guess
that's how I pictured it uh then I guess
Jessica went on to heaven or whatever uh
so they said the staff of the uh the
staff said that the atmosphere of the
place like uh got better considerably
after that and then that was the end of
the show but like I said there were a
couple of articles about this but and
they kind of went a little bit into some
[ __ ] that wasn't on the show as I
mentioned there was an article that was
in uh Chronicle live and it was first
published in 2004 and then updated again
in 2020 and this was about the psychic
Suzanne hadwin and she said and like I
said all of this is coming from her so I
don't really know I couldn't really find
anything to confirm that this little
girl actually existed but she said that
like the little girl was six years old
and her name was actually Jessica Ann
Hargreaves they didn't say what her last
name was on the show but she said what
her last name was and that she was
murdered in 1908 as I mentioned earlier
they she says on the show she implied
that there were more than one there was
a lot of spirits in there but she didn't
say how many on the show in this article
she said there were 37. eight of them
were children and one of them was
Jessica's murderer I don't know who the
other ones were
um she said that Jessica had been
strangled and raped and that Joseph cut
her up and trampled on her in the cellar
he tried to get rid of the evidence and
threw all her clothes and belongings in
a big fireplace so that's uh what she
said about that and she said he murdered
a lot of children and hid their bodies
inside
so she said that
and she said that she stayed there for
two weeks like every night she was there
she said that she managed to release all
the spirits into heaven including
Jessica but Joseph Lawrence had to be
forced out so she said that as well
um and then this article says Jessica
was a local girl her mother was called
Kathleen and her father Billy and Billy
the dad ended up killing Joseph Lawrence
they said like after he found out that
this guy had killed the daughter but
like I said I don't I mean if this
happened in 1908 you'd think that there
would be records of it like um
newspapers or something I mean a big
event it's pot yeah I mean it's possible
that like the those newspapers haven't
been digitized that's uh that's true but
I mean I couldn't really find any
confirmation of that you know what I
mean the only thing that was like
outside of stuff that was about this
show was find a grave and Define a grave
entry had obviously been made by
somebody that saw this show you know
what I'm saying when there were a lot of
men us murders
that happened you know what I mean that
we're kind of forgotten I mean there's
been some weird [ __ ] we're like in uh in
the 40s or 50s they tear down a house
and underneath underneath the house from
the 1800s there's [ __ ] 20 bodies
buried underneath it nobody knows what
it was
you know
so it's plausible maybe something like
that would happen but yeah I'm not
saying it didn't I'm just saying you
know right
that I that there's no record that I
could I couldn't find any record of her
like being uh Missing or anything like
that so I don't know I'm not saying it
didn't happen yeah I'm just saying that
you know that's most of the sources are
from this show okay well uh you want
that's it you want to go ahead and shut
it down I gotta [ __ ] start cooking uh
sure okay all right so
um yeah and like I said there was an
article that came out in 2019 too that
said there was another paranormal group
going there but because I couldn't find
anything more recent than that and I
went to their Facebook group and their
website and it didn't say anything so
I'm assuming they probably didn't find
anything and one of the Articles said
that the northumbria police had looked
into these supposedly like all these
bodies because apparently this little
girl's body behind the wall wasn't the
only one they said there may be like
eight other ones like underneath there
and supposedly they investigated it but
I'm assuming because I couldn't find
anything like official that they
probably didn't find anything or they
never did it they're asking what
tomorrow's review is I don't know like
whatever I'm gonna let Tom pick a movie
oh we're gonna do moving it okay yeah we
got to do a movie okay unless you want
to do another haunting episode but
um
or would you rather do a movie let's do
a movie okay what movie do you want to
do you have any ideas I mean you can
look yeah because I picked the one
before and it's like you don't like that
one too much so no I'm gonna let you
pick one okay
so you said you can't cry if you don't
wake up
[ __ ] I can't pick one off the top of my
head well no you can look through all
the streaming services and see what they
got yeah Hugo says Hellraiser 2022. I'm
actually gonna do a review of that and
I'll probably put it up on Saturday
and I'm also going to do a review of
speak no evil because I know one of you
guys recommended that to me uh and I
watched it earlier today and I wrote
reviews so I'm going to put that up
later uh Karen Lee says do Night Flyer
that's the Stephen King
thing I mean if we can find it
Halloween kills we already did that did
we already did Halloween kills right
because I thought we saw that in the
theater yeah I think we did that one
yeah I'm pretty sure we already did that
one it's okay
yeah but we'll I don't know we'll figure
something out we'll figure something out
I'll let Tom like scroll through this
[ __ ] and we'll find some stuff all right
so thank you everybody for dropping by
this evening and uh we'll see you guys
again tomorrow bye